i think the law of attraction and
manifesting are the same thing so law of
attraction for everybody who's not read
the secret is simply your thoughts
become things and it's true we've talked
all about how when you have a negative
self-talk it tends to
draw
more of that to you i think about it
like lint in a dryer once negative stuff
starts collecting it collects a lot more
we can also talk about your brain filter
or something called the reticular
activity system and how it is a live
network that filters the brain we'll dig
into that deeper but let's do surface
level right now manifesting law of
attraction so here's what everybody gets
wrong about manifesting everybody at
least kind of in the mass market what
you're trained to think about when you
think about manifesting is vision boards
and when you hear the word vision boards
you think about the big stuff
should you have big dreams of course you
should should you dream of building a
mansion on the ocean if that's your
thing yes should you dream of the log
cabin yes if you want a lamborghini or
the new ford broncos should you buy yeah
yes yes yes if you want the family if
you want the body should you think about
yeah absolutely here's where everybody
goes wrong you
dream about the end you make this
gorgeous collage of all this stuff that
has nothing to do with your current life
that literally as you're sitting in your
studio apartment with the cat box that
hasn't been changed in two weeks no food
in the fridge no food in the fridge and
you're looking for a job and you're
staring at a mansion going someday
it's going to make you feel like a loser
because the gap between where you are
and where you want to go seems
insurmountable and so what happens based
on the research is when you only
visualize the end game louis it's
demotivating at first it's really fun to
like have a bottle of wine and make your
like collage i'm gonna visualize i'm
gonna slap this up there's my vision for
it's fabulous law of attraction baby
come on i'm gonna think about it it's
gonna come to me okay i've been doing
this for two days i'm still in this
apartment with the cat box that needs to
be changed
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that's holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to
activate some powerful manifestation
enjoy
the way
to visualize properly is to visualize
the bridge
between where you are
and where you need to go the bridge yes
and particularly
the horrible stuff
so let's use your example of the
marathon
the vision board would be lewis crossing
the arms up with the battery
yes i did it exactly
that will not help you because when you
hit mile 13 on the actual race and it is
sleeting range you say why am i doing
this yes and it feels nothing like that
thing on your vision board you're going
to start a negative dialogue i can't do
this my knees hurt this is not what i
thought it was going to be i'm not ready
for this i didn't train for this i'm
running new york i trained in la are you
running in here l.a okay good well then
at least you're trained in the right
weather so on and on and on and you are
going to tank yourself
what you do by visualizing the bridge is
you train your nervous system
and your mind
to do the hard work
so you should visualize
not crossing the finish line but what is
it like to be at mile 12 when your
batteries run out on your earbuds yeah
i'm serious and you keep going
what's it like when your shoelace breaks
and now your heel is lifting and you're
starting to get a blood blister at mile
17. what's it feel like when you wake up
and it is pouring rain
and you visualize yourself
running anyway
that way when you visualize the work
you are preparing your body for it so
you're not resistant to it when it comes
yeah isn't that cool
i think it's great it's
a story that i had
george st pierre who's one of the
greatest ufc fighters of all time he
said that he always puts himself in the
most uncomfortable situations in
practice leading up to the fight
the most you know the hardest situations
to get himself out of when his arms are
behind his back and he's
facing against the the mat in between
the fence and he's just getting punched
in the face he's like how do i get out
of this right right he's like visualize
that and seeing how can i get through
this yeah yeah where it seems like i
just want to tap out yes instead of
tapping out what's a process for
figuring out how to get through it yeah
to then raise my hand at the end
victorious totally and so you are
literally building up
almost like this resilience and this
muscle inside of you to do the work to
get the thing so yeah create the vision
board but make sure in addition to
crossing the finish line you have
somebody running in the rain
right you have somebody who you have an
alarm clock that says 513.
you have you know these images
that show the stuff that you don't want
to do so like for people who want to
launch a business for example like a lot
of people that i'm sure follow both of
us are dying to launch a business or
interested in being an influencer social
media or making money online and what
you visualize are the checks or you
visualize the money you're going to make
or you visualize how cool it's going to
be when you're a lifestyle entrepreneur
whatever the hell it is don't do that
visualize working a day job and telling
your friends that you're not going to go
out tonight because you're working on
something visualize making cold calls
and being told no visualize not going to
that party because you're staying in on
a saturday and not going to the barbecue
because you're putting in the work
visualize sitting at a seminar and
learning from other people visualize
watching youtube videos visualize your
first ever course failing miserably
like
literally that's the sort of thing that
you want to visualize yourself doing and
pushing through because that's going to
help you do the work yeah isn't that
cool i think that's great yeah
visualizing so in order to manifest what
you want don't just visualize the good
things happening visualize the bridge
all the things it's going to take to get
yes and and and the hard parts of the
bridge because then you're ready for it
mm-hmm then you're like i don't expect
this reason is hard i mean it's still
going to be hard right but you're less
likely to quit rule number two embrace
the negative feelings with rhonda byrne
what does it mean to truly
embrace and welcome a negative feeling
what does that mean in practice because
i i couldn't agree with you more and
just to help people as they're listening
and watching the thinking you know what
i just right now i'm just there's so
much negativity in the world i'm
watching the news i'm stressed out about
this my kids are at home i'm having to
homeschool
how do they welcome that and and i agree
with you we resist completely we don't
want to feel negative well you don't
want to because it's not pleasant you
know feeling negative feelings so
and so when you
when you feel a negative feeling arises
in you
notice the feeling don't focus into the
feeling because if you focus into it
you'll just make it stronger the mind is
really powerful so don't focus into it
but notice the feeling and so and just
welcome it so it's almost like you could
imagine just putting your arms out like
this
arms out to the side of you
and just allowing the feeling which is
simply energy that's all it is even fear
it's just energy and just allowing it to
pass on through
one thing that i did was i
would
imagine
putting my arms around and embracing the
feeling and
and pulling the feeling in close to me
and i just found that that was amazing
for me i think people can try all kinds
of different things like i just imagine
that that feeling was one of my oldest
dearest friends
that i loved so much that i hadn't seen
in decades and they arrived at my door
and i was just like could not get my
arms around them fast enough
and that is what i imagined with each of
the feelings and i mean at one point in
my life i did that with depression
and so i wrapped and that's really how i
learned how powerful this practice is
because uh
when i
wrapped my arms around the depression it
just dissolved
and her and the relief
i mean the relief that you feel when a
negative feeling dissolves it's so good
it's worth every
it's like a high and the heart and the
reason it's like a high is because when
you dissolve the feeling there's you
underneath and who you really are and so
you get a flash
of who you really are this kind of joy
and happiness
and so yeah that's what i did i would
embrace the feeling and
hold it in without focusing on it notice
it but don't focus into the feeling and
and just let it dissolve and i promise
the next time you feel that feeling it
will never be as strong when you do it
and so you do the same thing the next
time that feeling arises
and then the time after that it's going
to be weaker it just gets weaker and
weaker and weaker until you get to a
point where you're like
i can't remember the last time that i
got angry
ass can't remember when did i ever get
angry
you know you're just all agitated or
impatient or and so you do it with every
feelings so
so my to give people a really good guide
i would say
that unless you're feeling
really happy joyously happy
welling up inside of you you have a
negative feeling
pretty good you don't need to know what
the name of it is to welcome it it is
welcoming you it doesn't matter about
its name doesn't matter what it is just
welcome the feeling or embrace the
feeling or allow the feeling to be there
and then you will begin to
dissolve these negative feelings that
are actually masking who you are the
more you dissolve them the greater the
happiness the rises within you rule
number three rewire your brain with john
assaraf i wanted to figure out if the
stuff that i did in the 80s when i was a
kid you know that broke free
would it work with some of my agents and
so we took 75 agents randomly agents
said hey do you want to get into a
six-month program too like retrain your
brain your subconscious brain around
your beliefs about what is possible for
you to achieve around your habits of
what you have to do in order to achieve
that
and we focused on retraining their
subconscious mind and so for six months
they had to go through a process of
listening to certain audio tapes reading
reading certain materials every day and
following the process of training their
brain specifically their subconscious
brain which controls 95 to 98 of all of
our thoughts emotions and behaviors
today
and within six months that group
increased sales by 100 million dollars
jesus 100 million dollars i said holy sh
right this is working and so we started
to teach some of what we teach now in
neurogym actually now we have the
technologies we have the systems that
are far better than what we did back in
the 90s and we went from 1.2 billion to
4.5 billion a year and it wasn't because
we taught them any more skills to be
real estate agents we taught them how to
change the way they thought about
themselves we taught them how to change
their habits
our agents who made 750 000 or more were
in front of a client 75 of the time
and we asked all the agents that weren't
in front of more clients like why are
you doing that like why aren't you in
front of people that are going to help
you earn more income oh well we're busy
doing this and doing this and doing this
and they had stories and excuses and
reasons why
and so part of the work that i love to
do now is is really help people
understand what is your story
like what's the story you're telling us
because we all have a story we have a
money story a relationship story a
health story we have a story for
everything and then that story keeps
recreating our lives over and over and
over again and we have beliefs that
support the story we have habits that
support the story we have people that
support the story we have systems that
support our story
and so my question i always ask people
who would you be with a different story
talk to me about set points that was
something really interesting in what you
talk about around the stories and things
that we carry that i found really
interesting sure so
maxwell maltz wrote a great book many
many years ago in the probably the 70s
called psycho cybernetics right and
maxwell moss was a surgeon who performed
surgery on people and what he noticed is
even after plastic surgery that he
performed on people some people didn't
see any change in their faces and it was
visible to everybody else but not to
them because they had a map of what they
thought they look like yes okay so we
all have
a map of reality we have a map of what
we think we look like uh and any
deviation on the physical level to that
map to that visual representation we
have in our brains that doesn't match
the map your brain deletes or distorts
it
so
when we were working with real estate or
when i worked with business owners in
addition to upgrading knowledge and
skills
if you think about how let's say income
we have set points for how much income
we earn so whether it's 10 000 a year or
20 or 50 or 100 or a million it doesn't
matter we get this set point and then we
behave the way we need to behave and we
feel what we need to feel to earn that
income
and over a period of time it becomes
part of the brain's default mode network
so we develop set points for everything
and so if the set points in the brain
and there's a psycho-cybernetic
mechanism in the brain a control and
response mechanism in the brain
and it's our brain
why not learn how to reset the set point
and so now we're looking at what
technologies are available to help help
reset that
what
evidence-based methods are there to set
that or to reset that
and so when we take let's say
visualization right and you start to see
yourself even if the picture is not
clear in your mind of achieving the next
level of your success whether it's
releasing weight and keeping it off
getting into a relationship that you
love and are happy and whether it's to
make two or three or five times more
money and live a certain type of
lifestyle that allows you to do the
things that freedom
with having money allows you to do if
you start in your mind first and you
impress
that through conscious efforts into the
subconscious mind
it then causes thoughts and emotions and
behaviors
so i like to work from the outside in
and from the inside out so use both
i want every advantage
it's interesting so i've heard you now a
few times and and the first few times it
didn't really make my radar but you
always say release weight you never say
lose weight yeah what do you do when you
lose something
look for it yeah i don't want to look
for weight that i've lost
i want to release it i like to use
language patterns
as well that are going to empower me
versus disempower me
self-talk is so critical
and so i'm consistently paying attention
to how am i speaking to myself
am i speaking to myself in a kind
motivating
empathetic compassionate way
or am i consistently self-deprecating
and putting myself down i used to think
a lot like when i was younger i'm not
good enough i'm not smart enough i'm not
worthy
those thoughts uh and you know lots of
fear fear of being embarrassed fear of
failure fear of being ashamed and i
still have the thoughts every once
especially when i'm setting new goals
those come up holy mackerel they come up
so freaking fast are you smart enough to
achieve that are you good enough to
achieve that even when i got into really
diving deep into the brain science and
even my new book i had i was petrified
to release my book it took me two years
to write it because now i'm entering
another whole domain of neuroscience and
neuropsychology with world-renowned
experts that i've worked with for years
but now here i am putting myself out
there with hey this is
neuroscientifically correct so i had to
make sure that it was
and but there was a lot of fear
but i understand what the emotion of
fear is it's a subconscious trigger that
causes this feeling that i don't like
and it's a ghost signal for me not a
stop signal for me that's interesting
what do you mean by that
well fear is an emotion emotions are all
triggered at the subconscious level
they release neurochemicals that causes
a feeling we are consciously aware of
feelings
that are triggered at the subconscious
level the feeling is the end point
of the human experience in the physical
body
and so when you have something in your
brain that that a neural network says
well
what if this book comes out and you fail
what if it's not good enough what is
scientifically not correct what if what
if what if my brain is going to process
that the same way as your brain and
everybody else because that's
everybody's brain is the same
the mechanism of how the brain works
it's einstein's brain hitler's brain
genghis khan's brain
tom bilio's brain john acetate all the
same functionality
so if you understand the mechanics of
what's supposed to happen
then you say okay great when i feel this
then what am i going to do
so i like to use an analogy of a car
you're driving a car
and you're talking to a friend of yours
and a light pops up on the dash you
don't take a hammer and hit a light
it's a signal something's happening in
the in
in the trunk in the in the tires
something's happening emotions and
feelings aren't uh positive or negative
they're
empowering or disempowering to varying
degrees if you don't understand
them
and so if you think about fear right
how does a firefighter
go into a burning building
when there's this enormous adrenaline
and an epinephrine you know that could
stop most people dead in their tracks
they learn
here's the feeling
it's normal
do you have the knowledge and the skills
and the preparation to deal with this in
a safe way
go
if you don't now you retreat so we have
this phenomenal brain right it's it's
it's genius abilities we can't figure
out how to
replicate it anywhere with billions of
dollars but we are getting some of the
user's manual now
so when you feel fear what should you do
i teach the first two inner sizes that i
teach every one of our students number
one is called take six com the circuits
so if you have this unpleasant anxious
fearful emotion energy in motion
right and it's unpleasant and the breaks
have gone on
if you just take six deep breaths in
through your nose
out through your mouth like you're
breathing through a straw you will
deactivate the stress response center
which means blood is going to go back to
the left prefrontal cortex the einstein
part of the brain can actually think
through this problem because what
happens when the stress response center
is activated blood goes away from that
into the fear response so you have
epinephrine cortisol adrenaline to be
able to get you out of this situation
it's part of our instinctual brain part
of the reptilian brain the first part of
the brain that was developed was that
then the mammalian brain the limbic
system then the neocortex the thinking
brain
so when our brain has this signal of oh
my god you might get hurt you might lose
this you might get in trouble you might
be embarrassed ashamed ridiculed judged
et cetera
that part of the brain is going to get
activated so if you take six deep
breaths first calm down calm the
circuits first
then do inner size number two is called
aya aia
the first day is for awareness
what am i thinking right now what am i
feeling right now what am i sensing
right now
what is my behavior right now
to you thoughts feelings sensations
awareness of behavior what's my
intention right now that's the eye
well my intention is to move forward i
want to do this
great what's one
very small action step that you can take
now the reason you want to take one
small action step
is one small action step
your brain can handle
if it's one small step towards it the
threat response goes away
but if you focus on the end game right
away
you're going to get that rush and that
instant trigger of the fear responds
stress response so the first thing you
want to do is learn how to manage your
mindset
and what you focus on learn how to
manage your emotions because they drive
your behavior more than anything else
because we move away from pain and we
move towards pleasure but we move away
from pain a thousand times faster and
pain wires in the brain faster for
survival mechanisms
so purely from a neuroscience
perspective just understanding self
once you understand okay this feeling is
normal okay what should i do
take six con the circuits
aya
and now you can start being progressive
and make progress towards what you want
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four switch your focus
to positivity with lewis howes the first
thing you want to think about is
switching from negativity to positivity
so many people get caught up in focusing
on what they don't want to happen in
their future and i want to talk about
this a little bit towards the end of
this video on how to focus on
some of the negative things that could
happen but really focusing on the
positive for the main part of your life
we'll talk about that towards the end
because this is an important distinction
but they start living almost in constant
fear of what could go wrong and what
won't work out and when we come from
this place of well i don't know if i put
myself out there you know it's not gonna
work out and then i'm gonna get made fun
of and then people i'm gonna be
embarrassed and i'm gonna be stressed
and no one's gonna love me and then we
go in this rabbit hole and this
kind of cycle of fear and anxiety and
that is not
how you attract good things in your life
you can't
start from your way of being of
negativity and fear and expect to
attract beautiful things in your life
so we we need to eliminate the negative
self-talk and an environment that's easy
to get stuck in sometimes can be the
negative self-talk and there's so much
negativity in the world and if you don't
actively work to shift your focus to
shift your thoughts and your mind that
negativity will consume you and that's
where the law of attraction comes in now
for me it's about focusing less
on what i don't want to happen in the
future and actually focus on what i do
want and again i think a lot of people
focus on what they don't want too much
and you start to attract the things
you're thinking about i don't want this
i don't want that those things start to
come to you you start to see them
it's like the exalt example if someone
says you know don't think of a pink
elephant you start to see it and you
start to imagine it and you say well i
don't want to be poor you start to feel
it and you start to imagine it and you
start to have anxiety around it so you
want to really think about the positive
things in your life you want to think
about what do i want to attract who do i
want to become what do i want to
overcome so for example if you're
becoming a negative person you're more
likely to attract
more negative people rather than
positive ones because positive people
won't want to be around you you know
negativity keeps company and so does
positivity when you start to see other
positive people that are like you you
say i want to hang out with those people
those people are going to continue to
lift me up i can lift them up it's a
good cycle but the negative stuff you
start to attract when you talk about
gossip and you talk about bad news when
you talk about comparison and judgment
and anxiety and stress
that feeds in a community of other
people that speak in the same language
so you want to shift your language and
start thinking more positively and if
you feel like you aren't deserving of a
loving relationship a loving partner
you're most likely going to attract the
wrong type of people in your life and if
you're focusing on how much money you
don't have in your life right now or how
your business could fail you're not
going to be able to focus your energy on
the right clients or the products that
will take your business to the next
level or the skills you need to develop
to help you grow
now your thoughts dictate your actions
and where your energy goes so you want
to be thinking about
what can i do to replace these negative
thoughts the anxiousness of the fear how
can i replace it so my energy can go in
a more positive direction and again
where you put your energy into is what
you attract
so if you're thinking negative thoughts
all day long you're probably going to
attract that if you're thinking
gratitude and positive thoughts you'll
start to see that show up differently so
how can we put the law of attraction
into practice now let's go back to our
examples and apply a new way of thinking
if you're caught and thinking negatively
about the world and about yourself this
is so important
what would change inside of you if you
looked around
and you wrote down five things that
you're grateful for about the world now
this for me
is part of the secret to the law of
attraction it's the foundation is
gratitude it's your way of being must be
grateful in order to attract new things
there's so many things in my life that i
should not have attracted
because i didn't have the skills because
i didn't have the tools because i didn't
have the education because i didn't have
the money because i didn't have the
resources
so many things that i shouldn't have
attracted but because i had the
foundation of gratitude
passion joy curiosity those things
started to come to me and they can come
to you as well if you come from that
place of gratitude as your foundation
so you want to think about what are
these things that are important to me in
my life you know it can be simple things
it could be like this cup of coffee that
i have right now it can be that i have a
roof over my head that i've got quality
friends that i'm healthy
you know that i'm walking in nature
today it doesn't have to be
some grandiose thing that's happened to
you to be grateful for i'm so grateful
for
these little present moments
with people that i care about to spend
an hour on the beach to go for a walk
with a friend to have a good
conversation with someone and talk about
something that i'm going through for me
that's just as meaningful
the moments in between the big moments
are just as meaningful so write down
these things or think about these things
this is something i embed in my daily
life when i wake up i think about what
i'm grateful for when i go to sleep i i
think about and reflect on the things
i'm grateful for from that day and it's
just my way of being for as much as i
can now i'm not perfect i make mistakes
and there's some times i'm negative
but it's something that i try to really
focus on as much as possible so instead
of saying that you're not enough
that you don't deserve success what if
you looked in the mirror on a daily
basis i dare you to look in the mirror
on a daily basis and say i am enough and
i do deserve
the results that i want to create in my
life because i show up because i'm
consistent because i work hard because i
care about my work
if you looked in the mirror and you did
this consistently for 30 days and you
actually
use the word action in attraction and
you put it into practice on a daily
basis towards that growth
i'd be amazed to see what you attract
and what you manifest in your life or if
you felt like you weren't deserving of a
loving partner and just kept focusing on
the wrong people what if you said you
know what
i am deserving of a loving partner
because i care deeply about those around
me and i am worthy of feeling deeply
cared about myself
and what if you started to change your
thoughts and behaviors around yourself
say i'm not going to keep doing the
things that i've always done i'm going
to start showing up differently and love
myself not needing someone else
to love me who maybe isn't in the right
mindset and start distancing yourself
from those typical patterns that you've
had in the past and love yourself first
and see what you attract from that
loving grateful place with yourself or
if you are in a tough financial spot
maybe you're struggling financially
you've been trying to start a business
or a side hustle
i've been there i know what this feels
like it's not fun for a long time i was
living on my sister's couch and i didn't
have much money it was really stressful
i remember this feeling of being stuck
feeling like i was never going to make
any money and when i was focusing on
that feeling of i'm never going to make
this money i feel stuck i feel trapped
when's this gonna happen
feeling this anxiousness this stress
around it
it was really impossible for me to think
of creative ideas it was impossible for
me to
take action because i was living in the
stress as opposed to the gratitude for
what i was having in that moment i
should have been focusing on you know
what my sister is allowing me to stay
here for free so i have some time to
learn a new skill
i made a hundred dollars this day i
should be grateful for that not a
focusing on what i'm lacking or what i
don't have but what i am creating on a
daily basis and i started to ask
different questions around this time
like how can i be of service to other
people how can i add as much value to
someone else or what are my top skill
sets that i can use
to my advantage that no one else has
like what do i have i started writing a
list of all these different skills that
i had even when i didn't think i had
many skills i still wrote down a list of
the qualities i have of the skills from
the past that maybe i could apply to
right now and when i began asking those
types of questions i started attracting
the people who needed my skill sets and
services and i finally started to make
more money than ever before because i
was thinking about serving others i was
thinking from a positive grateful
standpoint about helping others and
starting a side hustle which turned into
a business instead of thinking
negatively about not having any money or
i'm sleeping on my sister's couch and
why is it taking me so long to create
this and i'll never make anything from
this situation i started focusing on how
can i add value as much value as
possible to this one person in front of
me right now how can i serve them how
can i create for them how can i connect
someone to them that could help them
what can i do to add value and help
someone else achieve their goals because
i think as zig ziglar said if you want
to accomplish all of your goals help
other people accomplish their goals and
that's what i started focusing on not
what i'm lacking but how can i give and
how can i add value to other people when
you focus outward on service you start
to really attract some incredible things
in your life it's unbelievable the
ripple effect the domino effect one
person helping another person how it
comes back around to you and if you've
ever felt this for yourself leave a
comment below of this feeling you've had
when you started adding more and more
value getting out of the negative
situation inside your mind and in your
body
focusing outward on helping others it's
incredible the things you can start to
attract and manifest in your life
so we want to talk about practice for
reflecting on your life and i want you
to look at your relationships your
health
your business and the key areas of your
life that are meaningful to you and ask
yourself these questions who are you
spending too much energy on
think about this right now who are you
spending too much energy on in your life
literally you can write this down or you
can just think like who are the three to
four people in my life that i'm spending
too much time on
that maybe i don't need to be spending
this time on these individuals what
aspects of your health are hurting you
because your energy is spent on things
that don't support you that don't give
you more energy
for your business what tasks or projects
are taking up
so much time that are stressing you out
without much reward whether personal joy
whether it be actual financial reward or
moving a project forward what are those
tasks that you're
in control freak mindset
doing too much of it spending hours on
something that you don't need to be
doing start assessing these different
areas of your life and think about what
can i really let go of in this place to
start attracting more you know energy is
everything when you're thinking about a
law of attraction and you need to be
coming from a positive grateful abundant
feeling
in order to start creating more of that
you can't come from a feeling of lack of
scarcity of not enough i don't love
myself if you don't love yourself you're
saying to the world to the universe to
other people
why would i work with you why do i want
to connect with you why do i want to be
in love with you if you don't love
yourself so you got to start shifting
that way of thinking the way of feeling
the way of being in order to really show
up energetically around other people one
of my early mentors told me the world
makes room for passionate people rule
number five flip to a higher frequency
with bob proctor if i dial your number
i'm on your frequency
i will never get tiffany's phone to ring
all right and let me get your phone to
ring if i take a picture of tiffany and
i send it to a friend of mine in
singapore simultaneously with me hitting
send here in los angeles they've got it
in singapore you know that
yeah well thought works the same way
i could be thinking of you
i'll trigger cells in your brain
and your cells if you're not thinking
those cells will start jiggling you'll
start thinking of me
and
maybe i'll phone you and say this it's a
damaged thing we're just thinking of you
yeah how was all the time
we got to understand what's happening
you think on frequencies
now this has to do with goals when you
set a goal
you have to flip your brain onto the
frequency that the good that you desire
or that you need for that goal is there
so you you most people don't make the
decision because they don't know how to
get it
you don't have to know how to get it
that's why von braun said when kennedy
asked him how to get to the moon
the will to do it you're going to make
the decision
you don't make the decision when you've
got enough money or when you've got all
the resources you make the decision
when you make the decision you flip your
brain onto a higher frequency
and then you're on the frequency you
begin to attract everything on that
freak that's where the law of attraction
comes in
see the secret brought out the law of
attraction but it didn't explain it none
of them explained i didn't even explain
it and didn't get the time most people
don't even understand it you can only
attract according to the frequency that
you're operating on
attraction is the secondary law the
primary law is the law of vibration
that's a that's a primary law of the
universe everything in this room is
moving nothing rests this table's moving
it just appears to be still
the law of vibration decrees everything
moves nothing rests
well when you think you put you onto a
frequency
you can only attract what's on that
frequency
you think about a person a lot just
concentrate that person will phone you
or you'll bump into them on the street
because you you're thinking about it
yeah the law of attraction takes over
you can attract to you what you're in
harmony with well when you set goals
you've got to see yourself already there
that's called a mindset
a lot of people talk about mindset they
don't understand what it is they set
their mind on the frequency that they
have to be in to attract what they have
to attract
and that's how the golem is in the form
you get emotionally involved you're
you're so intellectually and emotionally
involved
the only problem is you don't have it on
the physical plane
yet
but it will manifest in time
we just don't know what the time is so
you're guessing at the time you reach
your goal rule number six eliminate
doubt with gabby bernstein how do i stop
the doubting
great christian so you are in school
you're registered for school
and you still have a voice in the back
of your mind saying oh it's going to
fall apart how it's not going to work
and so you've got this doubt okay
and my love you've been on this show
before i i absolutely on the instagram
show and now you're here on the podcast
and i just i love you and you're part of
our family here and i just want to
acknowledge you and all of the great
work that you do to stay
optimistic positive and upbeat
especially during this difficult year
that we've had so i just want to
acknowledge you for that first and
foremost yeah it's beautiful and so you
know christian when you've come on the
show in the past in very short periods
of time
you and i have had this opportunity to
go from despair like you could have been
in a really uh stressed out state to
actually really regulating yourself very
quickly within like minutes truly do you
remember what i'm talking about like
you've gone from you know being stressed
and nervous and then very quickly you
and i just start to just calm it down
and even just hearing the the tone of my
voice has been soothing for you and you
can just relax yourself just right now
in this moment with me and i want to
work with you on that for just a second
before we start problem solving okay
so i want you to just just regulate with
me and just listen to the tone of my
voice
and i want you to place your right hand
on your heart and your left hand on your
belly
and everybody watching can do the same
and i want you to just breathe in with
me
and on the exhale just let it go
take a deep breath in
and let it go
and how are you feeling now that we're
just kind of slowing it down a little
bit are you feeling a little bit more
relaxed just being with me
yeah okay
so in this place where you're just a
little bit more relaxed let's just talk
about
what's up okay
let's give power
to what's working
you're enrolled in school
and that's a very abundant thing
that's a big deal right it's exciting
yeah
and there's a part of you that wants to
self-sabotage the part of you that
doesn't believe there's a part of you
that wants to you know play it play it
down or
stay safe and i want you to give
yourself a lot of credit right now
because that part of you is just there
to protect you from
previous disappointments from old
experiences from what what was a
traumatic event for you as a college
student during covid when everything
started to shut down right i remember
that's when we first met right
and you were very activated in that
shutdown and it was really scary for you
and so i want you to look at this
this this sort of doubting that's your
language and just say oh okay
that doubting is just a form of
self-protection
that's all it is
but i don't want to give voice to my
fear because it's okay to say fear
appears false evidence
we're appearing
real but here hear me out for a second
what i'm actually trying to do is
unwind
the attachment to the fear having a fear
here and there baby is totally
acceptable
and understandable and common and
expected we're humans we've been alive
in a pandemic it's been a tough time
okay we've got some fear
and i want you to really look at this
experience of doubting as just
this part of you that's just been trying
to protect you because you've had an
event earlier this past year in 2020
where school was changed
your lifestyle was uprooted and it was
upsetting for you
right yeah and so there's just a part of
you right now that's doubting
and that doubting part
isn't real it's just showing up because
it's there to be a false sense of
protection
but i but i feel
as though if i have the doubt there then
i'll manifest oh no it's not going to
happen and i don't want that to happen
no and that's that's why you're here
right now on dear gabby because it's not
about the moment when we have the
thought it's about how much energy we
put into the thought right so you're
here right now and we're undoing the
thought we're undoing it together i
really want you to really be in this in
the second step of forgiving the thought
sweetheart okay because
that thought has had some purpose right
sometimes there's times in your life
where you may have had to doubt things
to protect yourself from disappointment
or protect yourself from something that
could be
but that's just a practice that's that's
not supporting you in this moment
okay
so i just want you to really bring it
down really look at the look at the
worry and the doubt and just see that
worry and doubt as just
a silly form of protection that you
don't actually need right now
okay
and in the moments
when it comes up
i want you to notice it and i want you
to say thank you for showing up thank
you part of me for showing up but i'm
good i don't need you anymore i'm
feeling good i i'm feeling faithful i'm
going to lean towards what's working
i'm i thank you and it's actually a
really powerful practice christian of
saying
thank you right thank you but no thanks
we're saying thank you for sharing
like for instance if somebody came to
you if you're feeling really good and
some a friend or a family member came to
you with a bunch of doubt and negativity
you christian i know you you're sassy
you would say
thanks for sharing but no i don't
believe that right
i want you to say the same thing to
yourself
thank you for sharing i know that you're
just trying to be protective but it's
not the truth yeah write it down baby i
see you get your pen out write it down
write it down this is the method called
thank you for sharing
so you talk back to your thoughts
thank you for sharing but that's not my
story people right
and here's the deal guys we all have all
these different parts of ourselves that
show up when we're activated and this is
in this case a part of you that's just
the doubter the doubters there okay
thank you doubter for showing up i don't
believe you though you're not true
thank you for sharing
but i choose again
thank you for sharing but i'm enrolled
thank you for sharing but everybody's
getting vaccinated thank you for sharing
but we have a new path ahead of us thank
you for sharing things are different
next year thank you for sharing but all
the schools want to be open thank you
for sharing i don't need you baby you
know you're you're okay i forgive you
you're not going to judge that part of
you but you're just going to say no
thanks thank you
i think the fear is coming from i don't
know if i'm ready because
ready because
like i'm like living with a disability
i've
i have so much dependence on my parents
and maybe the fear is coming from a
place of like like do you think you're
worthy of going to college
yeah yeah well listen you know christian
we've talked about this because you
you've been struggling with depression
right is that correct
and you've been very reliant on your
parents i'm so happy for you you have
such beautiful parents that have been so
supportive and caring of you
and the good news is they're not going
anywhere
okay
and that you can take risks and you can
go out into the world and you have a
secure environment
you have a secure safe environment at
home that you can always turn back to
that's always there for you
and that's a big blessing man
it's a freaking gift in life
and i want you to celebrate that and i
want you to stay so grounded in that
because
that security that you have at home with
your family
allows you to take risks
allows you to step outside your comfort
zone
allows you to go off to college and see
how it feels with the possibility of
what it could be right
so just really keep coming back to
what's safe for you
what's working what's secure
it's it's you know the second that i
start to remind you of how safe you are
your entire nervous system settles i see
it on you right now just so you start
relaxing you know
and so i just want you to just
remember how secure things are for you
remember how abundant things are for you
remember how strong you are and how much
you've been through and how much you
continue to grow through
and that will really give you a lot of
positive energy to move forward and take
risks and do things that are new
and i want to honor you and acknowledge
you for the
bigness of your life and how much you've
created
and all that you are capable of
and so
with the sense of security and safety
that you have at home you have endless
possibilities of what it is that you can
create even with a
as you said a disability i'm just gonna
say a gift of knowing all the different
myriad experiences of different feelings
that we can experience in this lifetime
okay
and that gift has allowed you to be this
compassionate open-hearted beautiful
person that i get to see on this show
and so i just i just want you to take it
one day at a time
say thank you for sharing to the fear
and then keep remembering i have a lot
of security
so it's safe to take it's safe to do new
things
i will always land on my feet
okay baby okay and number seven the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is work hard with garyvee hey gary and
gary's crew good evening from lincoln
nebraska i'm blake bolan actually
enjoying a malbec currently
pretty good one from argentina
but i was thinking about a question for
the askgaryvee show specifically one
pertaining to the askgaryvee book
gary in the book you talk about how you
believe our brains and what they're
capable of are vastly underestimated and
that science has yet to prove really
what they're truly capable of
you also mentioned as an example that a
few years ago you told your brain you
didn't want to get sick anymore then you
attributed the fact that you haven't
gotten sick to when you told your brain
that you didn't want to get sick anymore
now i recently stumbled upon the law of
attraction i'd heard of it before but i
really dug in depth in a audio book
if you're familiar with it and for those
of you who aren't familiar with it the
law of attraction basically states
whatever you focus on will manifest
itself so if you focus on the things you
want to accomplish and you believe you
can accomplish them they will manifest
themselves over time whereas if you
focus on the things you don't want those
things will also manifest themselves so
the point is to focus on things you do
want
so gary i'm wondering about the
relationship between your beliefs and
the law of attraction and if you could
explain how we in vayner nation can
leverage those concepts to better live
our lives both personally and in our
businesses
so gary really looking forward to your
response here and thank you so much for
taking my question
godspeed blake it's a really interesting
question yes i believe in some of that
stuff and i don't know how much the law
of attraction is different than the
secret sounds very similar these books
sell like crazy because boy does it
sound super fun right now if you're
sitting on facebook live or watching
episode 232 is that where we're on you
know like and you're like wait a minute
if i just say i want a yacht or if i
just say i want to be a pop singer or i
just want to say i'm going to be an
influencer i don't know what either of
those two books say but let me give you
what i've done go ahead please you know
the secret is basically based off of the
law of attraction because the law of
attraction is the like it's like
it's like the religion sort of say and
the secret is a book which is basically
plays on it it's very hux free from law
of attraction so listen i believe in it
comma
all of your actions have to then map to
it so like it's it's clouds and dirt
that's my version of it
i don't know if anybody talks about the
dirt i do
i do i know all you know cynical newbies
are like what's he gonna sell me on
nothing i'm gonna sell you on the
following hard work and don't buy my
hard work course because there isn't one
there's no hard work sessions there's no
hard work ebook it's just hard work like
so my answer to this is i believe in it
but then you have to make your actions
map it i want to buy the new york jets i
think about it i want it i start
building vaynermedia there's an
opportunity to sell my company sell a
piece of my company to thousands of
entities all of them pass
i then sell it for lest one entity an
owner of an nfl team
that's called putting your money where
your mouth is i didn't do that by acts i
knew what kind of life i had i could
have
dated and married a bunch of different
people but when i found what i needed
for what i really knew i wanted i went
in that direction
right like i talk about hr driven
culture and this and that and some
people be like ah you got a bad review
on glassdoor or four or seven yes that's
fine but come here
watch what i do every day you guys know
my calendar you see what i do you know
what's on the back end of this like
so my belief in the law of attraction is
blake believe in it believe in it but
then you have to execute against your
belief if you want to be an esports
celebrity
shouldn't you spend every one of your
minutes
selling [ __ ] on ebay buying a ticket and
then going to the esports con not like
oh i can't go to the esports con
work it's work like there's gonna be
nothing else like yes
work smart i can hear the cynicism
already i can read the comment from
sally right now but you gotta work smart
no sally i'm leaving rick alone for a
minute you know no sh
yes it's better to have a better
strategy and to work smarter but here's
the punchline nothing happens without it
and i mean a lot of it and the more you
want the more work you got to put in the
bigger your ambition the more you got to
punch that clock and you got to give up
fun and leisure and laziness and rest
and all of it so my belief is it's real
i live it
but my actions map to it it's like
intent i talk a lot about intent some of
the people internally razz me about it
they're like yeah cool but a tent
without your backing up the actions is
whack and i'm like i respect that but it
starts with intent so i believe it
probably starts with
visualizing what you want or the law of
attraction or saying it or putting in
the universe fine fine i believe in that
i live it the problem is i
disproportionately out execute everybody
else i know that talks about it and then
does nothing about it you know many of
you tweeted me that you're gonna buy the
cavs or the dolphins or the rams people
tweet me all day long that they're
buying another sports team then i go
look at what they're doing i'm weird
just let's establish something i'm very
weird i'm so broken in the way that i'm
so utterly competitive that i'm like i
live for it you know i live for
competition and so when somebody tweets
me that they're gonna buy the rams first
my waste seven of my minutes auditing
their lives
let me tell all of you something right
now i haven't seen the person that's
buying the rams before i buy the jets
people like to talk
show me
because that's the best part because
when you live on execution all those
days you have where people say you're
staging garage sales or you're not going
to do this or you're not going to do
that you know what the best part is
2023
2023 because then you get to say now
what
and 2047.
that's more fun
consistent action is the cure-all
whatever problem you have whatever issue
you're facing whatever big life you want
to create for yourself the way to get
there is not some
giant
short burst of effort it's the daily
consistent grinding action that will
help you accomplish your goals people
look at my channel
and a lot of new people have joined over
the past number of years hey welcome
board great to have you welcome to
believe nation it's a positive happy
place it's great to have you here it's
an honor to be a part of your daily
routine
if you go and look at my my channel my
main channel in the history
it took so many years guys so many years
of just making content and not seen any
results
i took i forget what the number is it
took five years to get to 9 000
something subscribers and another five
years to get to almost 2 million
subscribers now sitting over 3 million
subscribers etc
i haven't missed
an upload
every single day
for i don't know
eight years
something crazy like that
every day
i've made videos through
travel i've made videos through
elect electricity electricity
outages i made videos through breaking
my neck i made videos through my tour i
made videos through vacation i made
videos i made videos i made videos i
made videos i made videos on my videos
and you can plan you could prepare you
can get ahead you can
you can batch them
but i don't think your goals count until
they're hard
it's when it gets hard when when you get
tested
that's when you have to show yourself
what you're made of
even little things like
i remember filming at my dance studio in
toronto
and i had my camera guy and my assistant
and we're filming
and the electricity goes out
and then there's a fire alarm
they go i guess we can't film like the
first thing that
that my camera guy says is okay well i
guess we can't film i can't film with
this like electricity outage and then
fire alarm
fire alarm bom bom ba like you can't
film with that it's like i'm
i'm filming today
so i took my phone it was freezing
outside i took my phone went outside and
just started filming
because videos have to go up
they have to go up
i've made videos with my broken neck
i broke my neck and two spots had a
concussion
and i
next week i'm making videos
they weren't as long they weren't as
good
i'm wearing a neck brace if you look at
the old videos i'm wearing this giant
neck brace i got this giant scab here on
my forehead because i smashed my head
against the wall
when i fainted and that's how it led to
the concussion broken neck i'm still
making videos
not making videos is not an option
and so if you look at someone like me
who
is introverted and shy who doesn't like
the camera who always thought that
people who are famous had a big ego
who
i still don't like being on stage i
still get nervous every single time
but i still have a message
and i still want to serve how does
somebody
like that
have this kind of channel well because
of every single day making videos you've
done over 10 000 videos i've done over
10 000 videos that's crazy
not all of them are public
but even just on the main channel let
alone this channel on the top 10 channel
or the other channel 10 000 plus videos
over
12 years
why
how
it's just a consistent action
i think most people lose because
we overestimate what we can do
in a really
short period of time and underestimate
what we can do in a long period of time
you think by putting in three weeks of
hard work you're gonna crush it or
really if you just stayed on it like
you've guys you've had ideas you haven't
you've you have had an idea
that you loved you gave up on too soon
that if you just kept doing it this is
an idea that you had maybe three years
ago that if you just found a way to keep
doing it even part-time even on the side
even on the weekends if you just kept at
it you'd be in a different place right
now
something would have happened something
would have paid off
but we're too frustrated to get
something to happen right now and i get
it i'm there too i'm i'm impatient i
want immediate results i want things to
happen i'm putting my best i want this
video right now to be the best one i've
ever done and i put my effort to try to
make that happen and i fully recognize
at the same time that
it's a long game
that you have to keep going
and that it's your purpose you can't
give up on it
most people just quit too soon
you just quit too soon
and that's you quitting on your dream
and if it's your dream and you want it
to happen it's a daily consistent
action
to make it happen
so how do you do it let me give you some
tactics so that you can not just get
motivated from a message but actually
apply it to your life
number one you have to create a calendar
these videos happen because they're in
my calendar
i'm filming this on a tuesday
tuesday is my youtube day
i always film on tuesday i block it off
in my calendar
i just came back from vacation
and on the tuesday of my week i was
still making videos people say well
still work on vacation first off it's
not work like i like this this is fun
for me this isn't this isn't i have to
go make videos if that was my mindset i
would i'd be out i wouldn't do it
anymore
but also if you're on vacation you're
making videos or you're doing a little
bit of work
to spend three hours
of a 24-hour day
doing something
is totally achievable somebody uh one of
the people that i invested into
yesterday how do i take a vacation on my
business
like how do i my wife wants to know how
do i go on vacation to run this business
like you can still you can either plan
ahead and get ahead with all your
clients or you can still do some work
do you not have personal time are you
going to be around your wife 24 hours a
day does your wife not want to go to the
spa or spend some time on the beach it's
not about the three hours that you spend
working
it's about
the other hours at 21 hours you get to
sleep but whatever all the other hours
that you have in the day it's about
intentional time most of most people's
life is not intentional most of your
vacation time is not intentional either
if you were to spend 21 hours a day with
your wife
intentionally creating an amazing
relationship
then the three hours a day you're going
to spend working
is easy as nothing
so of course you can take time off
but you have to put in your calendar
you have to create a calendar that makes
sense for you schedule in when you're
actually going to make your dreams
happen
because otherwise it's a dream i could
say i want to make youtube videos but if
it was never my calendar guess what it
would never happen and this applies for
life too
every uh every afternoon
at 2 30 i spend time with nina with my
wife
we spend time in the morning i take an
intentional break at 2 30 we go to the
park we take we take the dogs with us
we
we stay inside and just be together if
it's raining like we'll spend time every
day every week at 2 30 because i want i
wanted to spend more time with nina
during the week weekends we're basically
all in on on the relationship but the
weekdays can be crazy you know so we
spend time in the morning we spend time
in the evening and i wanted to spend
2 30
it's 25 minutes together but intentional
25 minutes that intentional 25 minutes
is worth more than three hours to just
sit in front of a tv that's not time
together
you have a lot more time than you think
you're just not being intentional that's
the problem if you feel like you got to
the end of the week and you were so busy
but you got nothing done
and everything's falling apart you're
just not intentional with your time
so you schedule it in whatever you want
in a life whatever your dream life looks
like whatever your goals ambitions
motivations are put in your calendar
two
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
stop letting yourself off the hook
for not following through on your
calendar
i'm a little tired today because we just
came back from our trip i'm a little jet
lagged
from coming out from the west
i'm still making videos i'm still
videos have to be made they're going up
like when do you let yourself break
if it's in the calendar it has to happen
videos have to happen today i don't care
if i'm lying in bed i don't care
i don't care if i'm in the hospital i've
made videos from the hospital i don't
care where videos have to come up i
don't care if they're the best videos
the best
with what i can make right now
if i'm tired they might be lower than my
standard
but it's the best of what i can make
right now if i'm in the hospital it's
definitely lower than what i can make
out of the hospital but i'm going to
make the best of what i can make right
now
be the person who follows through on the
things that you say you're going to do
because the next time you put something
in your calendar the next time we see
you're going to get that goal or
do this project you're going to the next
day wake up and say i'm not i can't do
that i'm not doing that
you're starting to build the identity
either way of the person who follows
through or the person who doesn't follow
through
and every time you say yes to yourself
every time you do it when it's difficult
you start to build up that identity a
little bit more i follow through i
follow through i follow through so then
the next time you put something in your
calendar the next time come up with a
goal you start to believe that it's
actually possible for you to do it
because you're building that identity of
you being the person who actually
follows through
and every time you let yourself off the
hook every time you give yourself a
break every time you say it's okay i'm
not gonna do it today every time you say
that
you eat away at that other identity and
start to build a new one
the new identity of the person who
doesn't follow through
you start to believe yourself a little
bit less
the next goal you write down is a little
less credible you don't think you can do
it
you're going to realize the next day
that you're not going to follow through
and so it's a very
slippery slope to fall down
so step one is you build a calendar step
two is you become the person who sticks
to your calendar
who follows through on the things that
you say you're gonna do that's why it's
important to create a realistic calendar
don't tell me don't tell yourself
you're gonna make 100 videos a day every
day
you're going to make a thousand phone
calls a day every day
you're not you're going to write 100
love letters to your wife every day
you're not you're not it's not going to
happen
make it a realistic plan something you
can actually stick to
because again if you just stick to it
guys you will hit your goals
if you stop quitting on yourself if you
stop letting yourself off the hook that
idea you had three years ago should have
already come to creation because you
just stuck with it just stick with it
step number three so create a calendar
one stick to your calendar number two
three
the environment around you really
matters
videos like this really matters why
create the entspresso to be with you
every morning to give you the boost to
bring you people like john asraf and
oprah and elon musk and these people who
lift you up who inspire you hopefully
that's the intention every time
join a group like movement makers be a
part of a community be around other
entrepreneurs who are doing things we're
chasing their dreams who are trying to
make their thing happen when you're when
you create that environment and you
start to shift it
it inspires you to want to play bigger
it inspires you to want to stay
consistent when you are feeling at your
lowest low when you're about to quit on
the thing that you said that you want to
do that's in your calendar you see it
you see it today i'm supposed to do that
the god i want to do that
what brings you out of it
it's the habits it's the environment
it's the routine
watch another video
join our group like movement makers
get a mentor coach
have an accountability buddy
you have to be around the people who
constantly fill your cup who give you
light who lift you up who make you
believe and help you feel like it's
possible when you do those three things
your life will change
create a calendar
that mapped your actions
to your ambitions
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
and then be around the people videos
resources environment
that encourages you that lifts you up
and makes you feel like it's possible
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to activate the power of
manifestation check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe i'll see you then if
the person's doing the vision board and
they're saying when i get my new car i
get my new house i get my new
relationship then i'm gonna feel so
great well then they're back to the
program waiting for it to happen for
them